we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to david p
last week i said
i don't think it's a great idea for
bernie to run again
i gave my reasons why as a bernie
supporter myself in 2016 and 2020
98 of the reactions from the audience
were substantive and respectful two
percent of the reactions were people
calling me all sorts of names because i
thought i i think bernie's time has come
and gone he'd be
88 years old at the end of his term i
don't think it makes sense
um but here's a question that i think is
a good one which came up in response
take a listen
hey david
kyle from florida here i really liked
your take about bernie
uh
not running or running potentially in
2024
i was just curious
who would you like to see running if not
bernie okay um that's the one thing i'm
curious about is
is who could uh take up that mantle so
to speak
um so yeah i do like your take there i
think that
you make a lot of good points um
although we agree on a lot of things he
he might not be the
person anymore for the moment all right
so listen this is a good question who
who who am i interested in for 2024
i am not i'm going to give you some
names right now
i am not telling you that i agree with
every one of these people's politics
more than i agree with bernie's i'm just
giving names of people that i think are
interesting
and bring the energy i would like to see
these are people of varying political
orientations some of them because of
identity issues i don't know if they
would really do well but here's just
people i think are interesting and are
smart and bring good energy and they're
not in any particular order congressman
jamie raskin i think is excellent i
think he's brilliant
he actually is a progressive activist
you look at his background and he's a
progressive activist that's where he
comes from
he is very well spoken
and brings some good energy that's one
person that i think is interesting
katie porter the democratic
congresswoman i know a lot of people say
david does she have the experience or
would people vote for her i'm just
saying i really like katie porter's
energy and i think she's super smart
excellent in adversarial and debate type
situations i think katie porter is a
rising star in the democratic party
georgia senator john ossoff
very young guy
i love his energy i think he's brilliant
i think he's a fantastic speaker
interesting guy
pete budej do i love pete's politics
exactly no he's to my he's to my right
there's no question about that
but he is so good
when he goes on with adversarial media
he's good at succinctly and pointedly d
arming
disarming i guess we would say and
delegitimizing right wing arguments i
would love to see what he would do in a
in a more prominent position and then i
say i think stacy abrams is super
interesting and i think that she's
extremely
smart and well-spoken as well like many
of these uh other people so those are
five democrats that i think are
interesting that bring more the energy
that i want to see with a range of
different backgrounds and experiences
and identities so those are just five
ideas
and i'm not saying they would win a
primary uh they they all have reasons
why we might say well they're not like
your typical
fast-track democratic primary candidate
but those are five names i'm interested
in we have a great bonus show for you
today
the french people have re-elected their
president emmanuel macron
and
that's good but at the same time it was
much closer this time with marine le pen
and we're going to talk about that on
the bonus show
senator former senator orrin hatch the
longest-serving republican senator has
passed away at the age of 88 we will
talk about his legacy and twitter has
banned ads that deny climate change are
people going nuts of course free speech
first amendment etc we will talk about
it all on today's bonus show sign up at
joinpacman.com you'll get instant access
to the bonus show
lots of other great perks and you'll get
the show every day six hours before
everybody else
sign up at joinpackman.com
and we will see you on the bonus show